.
- Bonne route!
- Ils pédalent pour contrer
é.
- Alors, mon Louis,
on va penser à toi.
l'organisateur de l'événement.
- Moi, j'étais rendu au pointtt
que je n'étais plus capable
de vivre.
une chirurgie bariatrique
à l'Institut de cardiologie et
de pneumologie de Québec.
Il pesait alors 438 livres,
près de 200 kilos
LOUIS FRLOUIS FRLOUIS FRLOUIS É,
organisateur de l'événement
- En un an, j'ai quasiment perdu
240 de perdu ou à peu près.
- Il désire amasser des fonds
afin de permettre à d'autres
personnes d'obtenir ce qu'il a
de vivre et de se dépasser.
- Je ne souffre plus d'apnée
du sommeil, haute pression.
Je n'ai
trop de douleur aux genoux.
- L'argent recueilli ira
dans un fond dédié à l'obésité
L'objectif : 10 000 $
pour finecherche
et l'équipement.
ROSEMARIE CHAMBERLAND,n IUCPQ
- Ça peut être aussi banal
qu'acheter une chaise.
Mais lorsqu'une personne arrive
on ne peut pas l'asseoir sur
n'importe quel style de chai
Il faut vraiment avoir
une chaise qui est adaptée
que pour l'équipement, pour
ne pas que ce soit endommagé.
- La proportion d'adultes obèses
au Québec devrait atteindre 21 %
d'ici 20esse d'augmenter
depuis les années 80.
7 % de la population était
alors touchée par l'obésité.
La pandémie est une des ca
Plusieurs études révèlent
onfinement a changé
les habitudes alimentaires
et une baisse de l'activité
physiqueombreuses
personnes. Il est donc important
selon Louis Fréchette.
- Dans mon cas, j'assume
une partie. Il n
penser non plus que chaque
personne qui est obèse
est une personne lâche,
au contraire. Et subir
la chirurgie, ce n'est pas
facile non plus.
- Les experts demandentres de se
pour contrecarrer à long terme
les comportements liés
à l'obésité et ainsi prévenir
les comp Ici Mar Ici Mar Ici Ma,
Radio-Canada, Q